Hey,
what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and it's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
Yeah.
Ah.
Do you guys checking in on you?
I'm checking in to see you.
How's your week going?
You're almost there.
It's fucking Thursday,
man.
You're on the east coast.
It's almost lunchtime.
All right.
By the time this comes out,
it'll be lunchtime.
What are you going to get?
Huh?
You're going to go out and get something heavy.
Are you going to start the weekend?
Right?
Go out and get something healthy.
Bring the stomach down a little bit.
You feel a little more comfortable,
right?
A little more confident.
You go out to the clubs that he buttoned down,
shirt you bellies,
not pressing against it,
right?
While you're,
yeah,
I used to do a bit my act where your buttons are doing like the iron cross
hanging on to both sides of your shirt.
Like,
Hey,
yeah,
you don't need that.
Make life a little easy.
Why is this fucking thing only on one goddamn channel?
Oh,
well,
I'll figure it out.
That's it.
You're not sitting up.
The elevator only goes to the fourth floor.
It's where I am right now with my anger.
No more go to the penthouse.
Okay.
I've downsized my anger life.
I've moved down to a floor that I feel is just a little more affordable and
everybody can relax the round me,
you know what it is,
is I don't have any time.
I think that that's something I feel like that triggers me.
Bailey know Tam Bailey,
no time.
They call him Billy nor time cause you've got no time.
Yeah.
You know my wife knows I don't have any time.
Don't show you.
I don't have any time.
Uh,
but what does she do
the fuck was it?
Was it yelling?
Just set off one of my kids' toys.
I like that.
It's like a sound effects.
What did I just yell?
I'll see if I can make that.
But you're now go chin.
She's got this one frigging toy.
Yeah,
it's fuck.
It's fucking crazy.
I like it.
Cause there's all these different musical instruments and it teaches the kids
about it,
but I swear to God the guy's energy.
It's like Willie aims and Charles in charge.
You know,
he's like Charles,
the same thing.
It's like Bob and rock [inaudible] rock bup and Brooke picked four instruments.
It's a trip.
It's like,
buddy,
relax.
I don't want to hear you play an instrument when you're all fucking wound up
like that.
They're constipated.
Fucking sound coming out of your instrument.
Miles Davis turned around giving you that look on the bandstand.
Okay.
Relax a little bit.
Pop and rock.
Boppin rock is skewed LIPO.
Is that a trumpet?
Right?
You want to live in there?
I'm not a musical guy.
Fuck you.
I'm a goddamn comedian.
Speaking of which,
I want to thank Madison Square Garden for a and Rory Rose Garden for having me
on the garden of dreams.
And um,
this is really great.
Um,
charity where they basically,
you know,
underprivileged kids,
kids who are sick and all that,
they got a dream and they come out and they make it,
they make it come true.
It was really nice.
He was funny.
As I was doing the,
uh,
the press there,
I was doing the press and I'm,
Jeffrey Gurian was in,
I always fuck with him.
I always have a great time with them.
But uh,
one of the ladies in lines like,
do you know what this,
you know what this charity is about?
You don't,
and I just seen some kid,
you know,
in a wheelchair kid on a walker or whatever and it's just like,
Oh God,
do you know what this charity is for this?
I just was like,
no,
I don't.
No I don't,
so I'm going to come off like an asshole.
But the reason why I said that was because I really didn't feel like talking
about it.
You know,
once you have like a kid,
it just,
it affects you.
Like you have something to apply it to.
Where before it was like,
oh my God,
I feel bad for that and I'm just like,
I felt the whole fucking thing.
The parents,
the whole thing.
Tell us about the charity.
Yeah.
Can you go through the emotion of it at no,
no,
I won't be,
I don't know what it is.
It's Madison Square Garden.
They asked me to come on here.
So anyway,
so I go on,
I do this show fucking monster lineup of a,
of comics.
Everybody fucking killed fortunately.
Um,
I went on during the middle.
Seinfeld had to close it out.
John Stewart went on a second to last and,
uh,
Michael Change,
Jesus Christ,
he came in fucking murdered,
came in from SNL,
still at his jacket on,
just walked on stage.
Fucking murders,
leaves your fucking joke assassin.
Uh,
who else was on it?
Um,
John Malaney fucking murdering Lizer Schlesinger murdered Brian Regan.
Brian was how big the show Brian Regan opened.
That's how fucking amazing the show us.
Um,
so I was happy showing me.
I forgot somebody.
I know.
I did.
I know there was more than that.
Who else was on it?
Come on,
Bill.
Thank you.
I don't fucking know.
Um,
Steve Sherpa hosted the thing.
Uh,
one of the crew guys at Madison Square Garden,
his name was,
um,
you know what's cool and we'll go into the bowels of the place going over to the
,
uh,
the theater at Madison Square Garden where Eddie Murphy recorded Ra.
I always think about that when I was there and uh,
when I'm there and we were going through,
we had to go up the elevator and they had all the Ottawa senators like hockey
bags,
they will load them in cause the rangers were playing,
playing.
Then the next night and lo and behold,
the next night I'm back in La Cause I got up at 4:00 AM to get back to my lovely
wife and kid as you do as a dad.
Cause it's
not about you anymore.
You've moved down the depth chart.
What do you think?
You've got to get some sleep.
Their dad don't think so.
Ben.
No time in no time.
MMM.
Yeah.
I got on the fucking plane,
flew back here,
and then I ended up watching like a period and a half of the game.
And Lo and behold,
they cut to the,
uh,
they cut to some highlights from the garden guy.
They didn't show the show.
Thank Christ.
Um,
I was a little rusty.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I hadn't done much stand by.
I have to,
I did the,
uh,
did my special,
I was like,
I'm going to take some time for me,
you know what I mean?
Put my feet up and just thought of just what it was that fucking word,
those kinds of people use that regroup.
Just allow myself to just realign my synopsis.
No,
I just didn't feel like going out or anything and I was,
I was fucking,
yeah.
Wiped out.
And uh,
yeah,
I w I felt like a fighter that didn't spar,
you know?
Yeah.
Just be like,
man,
I'm the champ.
I got the belt right.
I just knocked out,
you know,
my last set was my,
uh,
my standup special fucking knocked that out.
I'm going to fucking champ over here.
And I got the old right there,
Fred,
the second I walked out this.
So I meandered a little bit in the beginning.
Then I got to go in and uh,
oh my God had this fucking hilarious moment.
My set where you know,
I was making fun of Michelle Obama because how do you not,
you know what I mean?
The level that she's been gassed up to.
Oh,
I'll,
you know,
she's the president's wife.
All right.
Let everybody relax.
Um,
that was basically my angle.
So you know,
you know,
fucking,
all the women are going to fucking lose their minds,
especially white women who also don't have jobs.
You know,
they get,
you know,
who are,
it was a lot of rich people there.
Right.
So I was a,
you know,
I was pushing their buttons.
What,
I mean,
in fairness,
the audience,
I was being a cunt
and I was saying,
you know how being a first lady,
it's not a job that extending what all excitements about,
it's not a job right.
And the Ada yet.
So I keep setting off that toy.
Um,
so I say,
and I just,
so you know,
I can't see into the crowd,
right?
So I just looked into the blackness of like the 10th row,
this voice that I just heard you like.
Do you think it's the Jami?
Yes.
I'm like,
all right ma'am,
I'm going to do me a favor.
You tell me how the fuck that's a job.
And the woman goes,
first of all,
it's sir turned out it was a dude.
Right?
So then immediately you feel like this fucking post me to tension a,
a gender neutral bathroom,
all his fucking energy.
And I just went like,
wow.
You know,
Guy Tell you you've got a high pitched voice.
She sounded like a woman.
Yeah,
I,
you know something.
I was really not enjoying this time and now I've realized that this is one of
the greatest times ever to be a fucking comedian.
The amount of fun that you have
and there was not,
you know,
you sound like a woman and you know what the nowadays is just say,
well what is a woman sound like?
You know what a woman's sounds like.
You know what a guy sounds like,
you know the base fucking thing.
I hate when people do that.
That would have up during the Oj trial when that guy said it sounded like a
black guy and nobody's,
he's like,
what does a black guy said?
You know what,
the fucking black and what is an Irish guy sound like?
What does the German guy,
what does a French guy sounded like this accents
not say it.
Everybody sounds like that.
You know what I mean?
What if you met a black guy going like,
oh,
how are you a top of that morning?
[inaudible] you'd be like,
this guy is fucking with me.
But because it's a trial,
it's somebody sprayed.
It was all the wine
you have to take into consideration that this might be the anomaly.
Now I understand that.
But to say that somebody saying,
you know,
that sounded like an Asian dude,
that there's something like fucking,
I dunno clannish about that.
I guess there could be speaking to that where it tell you one time I was in San
Francisco,
right?
Visiting the bath houses.
Um,
and,
uh,
I got into a cab and this Asian dude was driving.
Yeah.
And he had the,
he sounded like he was on fucking he.
Huh.
So there is always that exception.
I swear to God,
straight up Asian Dude.
And he was just going,
wow,
man,
I'm telling you this traffic out here,
it's ridiculous.
And I'm looking at the Dubin is this guy fucking with me?
Hi,
I'm alone.
Y'All gone be out here in San Francisco.
And I was just like,
dude,
I got to ask,
where the fuck are you from?
And he laughed.
He's like,
man,
I grew up in Tennessee.
I know it's fucked up to hear me talk and lock this bowl where I grew up,
everybody dead.
Then he started telling me how he did all this extra work and how he was an
extra in cleaning clean Eastwood's uh,
one of those dirty Harry movies.
And I got his phone number and I bags when I was back on Opie and Anthony,
I was like,
oh my God,
we gotta get this guy on the show.
Um,
so there is an exception,
but I mean it's all,
but there's also,
that's not a reason to,
uh,
what are the kids call it now you've been canceled.
Um,
you sound Latino.
Just exactly.
What does that mean?
Did I tell you that time I was going to Charlie Murphy's funeral and I,
I had packed hastily.
You know what I mean?
Cause you never know when someone's going to pass away.
All of a sudden it's like,
shit,
we gotta go.
So I,
I,
and I forgot to pack my underwears there.
So where I,
uh,
was staying in New York was,
had become the gay part of town.
Right.
And,
uh,
cause it didn't used to be gay,
used to be fucking shady and then all the gay moved in and then,
you know,
what happens?
All of a sudden this nice restaurants,
there's a nightlife,
there's fucking mood lighting.
It's,
it's a,
it's awesome.
Right?
So right across the street from where I was staying was this clothing store.
And I'm not going to lie to you,
you know,
in the fucking windows.
They definitely had like the,
the mannequin with the leather underwear in the hat.
But I mean,
I had to go,
but I saw they had other fucking tee shirts in there.
So I went in there trying to find some underwear.
So I figured that was just like an aisle,
right?
That dog collar,
gimp aisle.
Right.
So I go into this fucking place and I'm trying to find underwear and all that.
God is like the fucking,
and like I finally find an underwear cut that I can wear to a funeral.
All right.
Rather than wearing the,
uh,
Greg Louganis goes to Brazil,
fucking cut.
Right.
So,
yeah,
I finally find the cut and then on,
on,
I know I've told this story before,
but there's always new listeners,
right?
On the waistband it said nasty pig,
you know,
and in the funeral,
the,
the service is like fucking 90 minutes away.
It's out in jersey,
and in time he's become an issue.
So I walk up to the counter and there's this dude standing there talking to the
person behind the register and I kind of interrupted.
I was,
excuse me,
I don't mean to interrupt.
I go,
do you have any like,
uh,
like mainstream underwear?
That's what I said.
Do you have any mainstream underwear?
And the guy got offended.
He's like,
define mainstream.
I just stayed in the pocket.
I was like,
oh,
I don't know.
It doesn't say nasty pig on,
on,
on the waist
band.
And then he had nothing.
Yeah,
he was trying to do that.
Like,
you know,
try to make me out to be like homophobic.
Okay.
Fucking come home to my wife off the road.
Which underwear that says nasty pig on it.
Okay,
honey.
I swear to God,
I was going to a funeral and I,
I needed some underwear.
There was a glitch.
They had his blow.
Right.
Oh son.
I'm Gus Grissom of fucking underwear.
Anyways.
Um,
so that ended up being a lot of fun.
Yeah.
And I finished my set and I said,
thank you.
God bless everybody,
including you,
sir,
with you high pitched voice.
So,
I guess I was a bit of yeah,
cut.
But um,
so last night,
right.
And I and I really did not like that feeling of um,
be in like rusty or whatever.
So I mean I already look rusty.
Um,
remember Rusty Jones?
Hello.
Goodbye.
Ello Rusty Jones.
Good bar rusty.
Cause Ya know,
she be able to make a living doing that.
Writing jingles.
Eight second songs.
Yeah.
I'm a pastor.
He's a puppy.
She's a pepper a of pepper.
Wouldn't you like to be a pepper to be a pepper Drake?
Dr Pepper Bam House in the Hollywood hills whores by the pool.
Cocaine on the piano
stays are all gone.
It's in the second you make it.
Somebody takes it on the Internet and then they do a mash up right with the
fucking,
I don't know the cocacola song.
I don't know how that fucking works anymore.
Okay.
That was a job when I was growing up.
You'd have a,
you'd have a party and then there would be somebody at your house.
One guy was a milkman and not another person wrote jingles for commercials.
Like there was always somebody in actuaries to sizing everybody up,
trying to figure out when you're going to die.
Oh,
he's already got 22 pounds overweight as far as my visual estimate goes.
And that is a second helping of cream of spinach.
I can't be good for the arteries.
I'm going to want to say,
that guy's going to tip out around 57 it was a dangerous age when I was growing
up.
57 you know,
that's when you were in the red zone of having a heart attack.
57 fucking 63 61 a lot of guys dropped at 61
mmm.
Which doesn't seem like a big deal.
When I was like five,
six,
you know,
fucking guy was born in like the 19 early 19 hundreds he had a great run,
right?
Like I was alive when Babe Ruth,
this was in shape.
But when all of a sudden you're 50 stare down the barrel of 51 in June,
oh my God.
Oh my God.
I was,
uh,
I want,
so I go to the airport,
right?
Like,
pick up 10 or five is what it actually was,
right?
And I get to the airport like five 30 crews right out to fucking JFK.
All right.
I got my,
I got my ticket on my cell phone.
All right.
I'm a modern man.
I'm not checking any bags.
I'm a little buck and Mr Technology,
so I'm precheck Tsa,
right?
I fucking go through that shit.
And I got my ticket and I just fucking,
I go,
I just put my phone down to the thing and I,
and I,
I set it down on the thing and I,
on my cell phone case,
I got,
oh,
I got this cluster of pictures of me and my lovely daughter,
right?
So I set it down and you know,
there's a woman there,
so you know,
they can't resist the kid.
She sees it and she just goes,
oh,
I go,
yeah,
isn't she a beauty?
And she goes,
yes.
She goes to set your granddaughter.
Ah,
Oh,
did that hurt?
And I laughed.
I said,
no,
it's my daughter.
I go,
I got a late start.
Oh.
And then I just limped through fucking security.
I had such a fucking spring in my step.
I'm like,
I haven't boozed comp 130 days.
Right.
My skin's clearing up.
I'm drinking fucking smoothies.
Hmm.
I'm looking younger than,
than my years.
And she,
oh my,
she just said she sent me,
she fucking fucking me in
right on top of the rocket and just shot me right back to the reality of my
fucking age,
man.
Oh man,
that killed me.
Yeah.
Fucking kill me.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
I thought I'd tell this story and then have a joke at the end of it,
but all I have is just the raw emotion of that,
that really fucking hurt.
You know,
see,
you go ladies there.
There's a pressure.
This,
this stigma when you're a bald,
redheaded male.
Granted.
But the reality is,
is I am,
I am old.
I am.
If I had a kid at 25 my kid would be coming up on 26 and if my kid had a kid
about the same time I did,
then fuck it.
I would,
I would be old enough to be a grandfather.
See,
so I'm not going to get mad at her.
I'm not gonna write tsa.com and be like,
I was so triggered when somebody stated a fact about my age.
You know what?
I'm going to take it and we'll take a look book.
Um,
what did I want to talk about here?
Oh,
I got so much.
Not so much shit.
I got a couple emails from these fucking f one snobs because I was talking about
how rooting for Ferrari's,
like rooting for the,
uh,
the Kansas City chiefs and it was painting them as an underdog.
Now,
even though I clearly stated that,
I just started watching like fucking three,
four years ago,
Ferrari has not been doing well.
All right.
Second place a that,
that,
yeah,
that's your,
you're the first loser.
So what I said was accurate and they're sitting there talking down to this
father who looks like a grandfather talking down to me.
This person who has difficulty reading out loud,
talking down to me the hero of this podcast,
the greatest person on this podcast,
right?
Yeah.
Now is me.
And it's not because I'm,
I'm the only voice.
It's because I'm the only one who votes.
Um,
yeah,
giving me shit.
Like I didn't understand that Ferrari is,
I know what a Ferrari is.
You fucking morons.
Everybody knows what a Ferrari is.
I know their history.
I actually read a,
I read this book called the limit about the first f one American f one champion.
One of the great fucking books I ever read.
I wish I didn't give it away.
I always give away the books.
Um,
absolutely fucking love that book.
And I understand.
I understand.
Okay.
I know where it's at.
All right.
I'm just saying the last couple of years,
I mean,
ever since I've been watching the sports since like 2015,
2016,
whenever the fuck I started,
it's just been Mercedes.
All right.
I'm getting sick of it.
I,
you know,
the same way you guys are sick of the Patriots,
I would like to see Ferrari make a run.
Although since then I did see,
uh,
that new guy,
John,
what's his face there?
The,
the,
the new drivers,
not Kimi Raikkonen the new,
the new guy,
uh,
driving for Ferrari.
He's like,
ah,
man.
You know,
well,
I guess we got lucky that the safety car came out and he was really positive
about it and that made me,
um,
that gave me some hope.
It gave me some hope.
By the way,
we're going to have a fucking benefit for fucking Daniel Ricardo yet,
you know,
they always doing standup benefits.
I want to do a stand up benefit to get that guy who fucking team that can give
them a car that's going to be able to finish the fucking race.
That poor bastard.
I swear to God,
if they take the smile away from that man,
you know,
that's,
that's really going to be a difficult fucking
thing to watch somebody so young,
so full of life,
you know,
twinkle in his eye.
How many fucking times can you just be driving,
crushing it and all of a sudden your car just shuts off,
you know?
Or for some reason somebody puts a mogul in the goddamn grass and you try not to
get sideswiping you go over just to Cantera under the grass in the front of your
car,
fucking explodes.
I don't get it.
The guy's fucking snake.
Bitch,
snake,
bitch.
Snake bit.
Sorry.
[inaudible] oh,
so I finally,
I saw the uh,
did I tell you guys,
I've,
I saw the uh,
I saw the moto GP from Ah,
Argentina.
Um,
I got a lot of questions.
All right.
Is I take a sip of a green smoothie,
a green smoothie.
You guys want a good recipe for a smoothie.
Green smoothie.
Here it is.
Cup of ice,
Cup of almond milk.
Sorry.
Starting over again.
Quarter Cup of ice,
Cup of almond milk,
a banana,
a cup of spinach,
a cup of all net.
I mean a couple of,
a,
a tablespoon of all natural honey.
Two tablespoon of a instant oatmeal and one tablespoon of almond butter.
Just try to get all natural,
everything.
This is how I do it.
I put the ice,
the almond milk and the spinach in first and then maybe like some of the honey
because what happens is,
you know,
the way you do it,
like sometimes it can turn into like a shake if there's too much ice,
but there's not enough ice in it.
And then I blend that.
Then I put the paint,
I put the banana in there first and then I put in the uh,
the peanut butter.
Now the oats and then the peanut butter or whatever.
And that way it stays on top of the banana and it doesn't sink all the way
fucking down cause like it's,
it's really the peanut butter in the honey.
It's going to stick down to the bottom and it won't be part of the fucking mix.
So however I just said that,
don't put the honey in where I said that flipped the oats and the honey and mix
it up that way and you should be good.
I do like to see two separate Mexicans.
There you go.
Drink that fucker.
Drink your breakfast.
Be a champion.
Be like a dad.
Looks like a grandfather.
Oh God,
that fucking killed me.
You know,
I swear to God just for men actually gave a shit about men with red beard's.
I would've gone out and bought some,
like if they were selling it on the plane and I would've been quite quietly
crying to myself as I combed it into my chin.
All right,
here's my question about the moto GP.
I don't get,
what the fuck is with mark.
Mark has his fucking motorcycle where it's just,
they,
they even called it,
you know,
he might just take off and this could be a boring race and then the guy quickly
correct himself,
not saying that it's going to be boring.
The guy just fucking,
you've got a good start and he got out front and he had like a fucking 15 second
lead by the middle of the race or something.
Something crazy.
I don't understand why his bike is so much faster.
I thought that the Ducati's or the do caddies were all on like the same level,
but he just pulled away like,
you know,
he had the IROC Z and everybody else had the rally sport or the Berlinetta,
the Firebird versus the Trans am I've,
I,
it's the exact opposite of f one.
So then the whole fucking race,
the exciting part of the race was watching a to CEO.
So in um,
uh,
Valentino Rossi battling for second place and he would,
Mark Marquez was so far out into the front
that they just had them in a little square on the upper right hand side of the,
of,
of the uh,
my computer screen here while we just watched everybody else battle and I don't
understand what happened or Halo Renzo did.
He pushed the wrong button cause he's also drive riding a Honda
and then they were all bitching about the visio zone is his little aerodynamic
thing that cooled off his back tire.
They thought that was ridiculous advantage.
And then the very next race,
all of a sudden this guy,
you know mark mark has just takes off and it's,
it fits.
He also still has that thing cool.
And his back tire,
I guess what they should have done because they were so busy fucking with each
other trying to pass each other racing.
What they should have done is just accepted that the vizios so was in second,
they all got in behind each other.
Like the Peloton is that I said in bike racing and eventually they would cut
through the wind and catch up with the guy and then once they caught up with
them,
then it can be like,
all right,
let's start racing again.
Is that legal to do that,
to actually become a team,
to catch the fucking guy who was already eight seconds in front of you?
I Dunno.
And then lastly,
uh,
cal crutch,
Lowe says name.
He got fucked on that race.
He got fucked.
All right?
He had an incredible fucking start until the naked eye.
He didn't start too soon.
And the fact that there's a goddamn computer now,
like people's brains are not as good as a fucking computer.
Can't see that thing.
So he doesn't know he's cheating.
He just started,
he got a good fucking start.
Hey Man,
they fuck that guy over.
They fucked him over.
All right,
so there you go.
There's,
there's my little motorcycle talking.
I'm going to read some advertising and then I'm going to wrap this fucking
podcast up and I'm going to get on with my,
my day here.
All right.
Oh,
here we go.
don't do me undies.
Me undies.
Bailey is old in gray.
Doo,
Doo Doo.
Mandy's me on Ds.
That's what the lady say.
You have a beautiful fucking granddaughter
started my granddaughter,
right?
Nothing rhymes with daughter.
I'm too fucking old to make it so fucking work.
Somebody get me a journal,
a journal tool and some soft fucking underwears.
Okay.
Buzzfeed said this about me undies.
They feel like actual heaven against your skin.
We're going to assume heaven is really soft in this context.
Well don't you pay bud buzzfeed or do they just review shit?
I don't ask men.
Well isn't that a nice magazine?
I'd like to be asked.
Things feel like I'm being heard.
As men said,
they feel like silk drenched in hand.
Lotion,
silt,
trenching,
hand like I know hand lotion makes your hands soft.
And I know silk is soft,
so if you combine both of those,
but you also jerk off with lotion and if you tea,
if you put that on the fabric,
now the fabric is wet and it's going to be sticking to your balls.
All right?
This is why you don't ask.
Men thinks
these honorees are so soft.
They make Bob Ross's voice sound like Gilbert Godfrey.
They are so soft that Kenny g thinks about them to get inspired to write his
next son.
Kenny g taken a hit there.
What did Kenny Dell,
me undies uses the coveted micro modal modal fabric that is a full three times
softer than cotton.
Take that big cotton.
Your big puffy on.
Yeah and cotton's also white to you.
Fabric,
toxicity fabric.
Patriotical cunt.
Speaking of Prince,
why not match your bottom half with your better half and get a matching prince
for you and your partner?
Uh,
me undies is also,
do they have like underwear for alternative a couples lifestyles?
Yeah.
Says nasty pig on one and says a nasty pig too on the other one.
Uh,
Mandy's is also the Goto for the softest lounge where on this side of the
Mississippi hang out and they're super comfy lounge pants and onesies.
Yes.
Mandy's makes onesies and they're incredible.
[inaudible] has a great offer for my listeners for any first time purchases.
When you order me on these,
you get 15% off and free shipping.
This is a no brainer.
Get 15% off a the most comfortable underwear you will ever put on to get your
15% off your first pair.
Free shipping and 100% size life guaranteed.
Goto me undies.com/ [inaudible] that's me.
[inaudible] dot com slash burr m E.
It's like the me too thing except it says undies.
Hashtag me undies.
Alright,
butcher box everybody.
Ah,
here we go.
Butcher box delivers healthy 1% grass fed,
grass finished beef free range,
organic chicken and heritage breed pork.
Did you guys see a Naples gutsy special yet?
Uh,
the Tennessee kid fucking a guy guys.
Absolutely brilliant.
He has a great bit on free range chickens versus the ones that they,
uh,
that were not free to range about a,
it's on Netflix streaming.
Now look at that.
It's an ad within an ad.
The incredible quality of butcher box meets.
Start with the commitment to raising animals humanely and free of antibiotics
and hormones.
Cook with the peace of mind knowing you are eating healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individual size meals.
If you're a city slicker.
But if you fastball province subject,
that's all enough for you,
for your friend,
you can choose from five different boxes.
All beef ladies,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box for you.
Progressive People.
Custom box lets you choose your own cuts.
That's for the conservative.
You know,
that's for the,
the people who want to keep their meat separate.
Once the overall only take these,
they are the Iris Katz's Deli meats.
My favorite cut of meat is their heritage,
which breed pork.
Oh Man.
And I have a fucking recipe.
I was at the airport there.
Oh,
grant,
grandfather bar here and GRANDPA.
And I was uh,
it was,
it was basically show,
now you can make all these meals and just one pot.
You know what I mean?
You know those great fucking things that comfort food that's going to make you
fucking blow up.
I got a good one for pork chops.
Then I'm going to try this weekend.
Oh,
I can't wait.
I really am like a grandfather.
I'm excited about cooking pork chops.
All right.
This month,
butcher box is offering the unlimited breakfast breakfast bundle.
What is this?
This includes two packages,
a bacon and two pounds of breakfast sausages all for free in your first box.
Our Bacon is the best bacon you've ever had.
It's whole 30 approved.
I don't even know what that means.
What the 30 people run in the bacon world.
Uncurated nitrate and sugar-free.
This sausage is a healthy,
authentic version of a classic style pork sausage.
My mouth is watering,
like literally reading this,
simply seasoned with salt and pepper and sage.
Oh my God.
What a way to start the day I eat that.
I would start crying looking across the table and life would be like,
what's the matter,
honey?
It's just so good.
Um,
right now new members,
we'll get two packages of bacon and two pounds of breakfast sausage added to
your first box for free.
Plus you'll get $20 off your first box.
Go.
Now while supplies last as this is a limited time offer.
These people know how to do it.
All right?
You want Americans to buy your beef,
you dangled free bacon and sausage in their fucking face and you set a
Jesus Christ the amount of fucking,
you know what?
So you know the amount of fucking people in overalls right now that are like
half hard listening to this overall,
is that like the onesies for rednecks?
You know,
that's when they know that they grew up.
I ain't got no sleeves and my,
hey buddy,
you don't know who you fucking with.
Ain't got no sleeves or or or fade on my one Z.
I'll walk out sad,
my onesy.
That's how I'd do it.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast.
Everybody,
uh,
please enjoy the,
the,
the musical interlude.
And then there's going to be a hat,
another half hour bonus here of a Thursday afternoon just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
A greatest hit.
I'm an episode from earlier.
Um,
so I didn't even mention last night.
So I went out and I did two sets.
That's right.
Cause I didn't like feeling rusty and I,
uh,
I got this whole new chunk and it came last night and had a great set.
And then Brian Kaylin probably said some of the nicest shit anybody said to me
as,
as a comedian.
I think he's absolutely fucking brilliant.
So,
uh,
I'm actually gonna call him today and thank them for the compliment.
It put me on a standup high,
you know,
which being the age that I am,
I,
you know,
I got called the grandfather and I,
and I have an Aa,
our p card and I've still never fucking used it.
Okay.
And if you're young and you don't know what it is,
that's,
that's awesome.
Enjoy the part of your life where you don't know what an AAR,
you're not qualified yet for one of those fucking things.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Enjoy the music.
Have a great weekend.
You cunts and I will see you on Monday,
Huh?
Huh.
Okay.
Hello.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's build births.
The Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 4th,
2011 or 2011 as I saw it so succinctly put this weekend by a,
the great comedian Patton Oswald.
That's how he said it.
He was on stage.
I was doing a show with them,
the Kevin and being April foolishness show.
And uh,
I noticed at some point at the Gibson MP theater,
by the way,
formerly known as
the Universal Lampi Theater for blues brother fans.
You might recognize that name right?
Remember that?
Good Evening Ladies and gentlemen,
welcome to the Universal Lampi Theater.
Here it is something,
something going on.
1985.
So much in music today is preprogrammed electronic disco.
That's where the fuck they did that.
They were opening for Steve Martin at the height of Steve Martin's career when
you had the white suit with the bow and Arrow going through it.
So that's the second year in a row.
I've got to do that wonderful program,
show performance,
whatever the fuck you call it.
And,
uh,
it was an awesome night of comedy,
but there was something learned and all the filth and fun to read that I saw
that night was pat and said 2011.
So that's how I'm saying it for the rest of the year,
cause I can't say 2011 I have to slow down.
2011,
2011 season runs together.
all of a sudden everybody in the room relaxes.
Hey,
well with the friend,
we thought that that red headed guy was,
was,
you know who,
who's left handed some of the times was a spawn of the devil.
You know,
that's what they used to think about red heads and people who wrote with their
left hand.
So basically I would,
if it was still the 18 hundreds,
I would be getting the shit slapped out of me and one of those fucking schools,
you know,
that they used to have on little house in the prairie.
We had grades two through eight.
We're all sitting in the same room.
Um,
tell me that was an inappropriate behavior going on there.
You know,
you're a senior in high school,
right?
All of a sudden the freshman girls come in,
there's always one pervert.
Your grade would descend on to someone who was basically a fucking child at that
point.
You can't tell me back in the day in the 18 hundreds when people got married at
14 so they could pull together,
there's showing so they could go buy a fucking plot of land in some oxygen.
Huh?
You're telling me some eighth grade,
it wasn't rolling up on a fourth grader,
you know,
like some Catholic fucking Prius.
I'm like a start that goddamned debate again.
Um,
speaking of which,
hey,
you know what,
for some reason the theme delivered and Shirley's in my head today,
we're going to do it.
I'll think of that's been in my head before,
every once in a while TV that I watched way too much back in the day,
uh,
pops into my head.
But anyways,
getting back to the,
uh,
the Catholic Church thinks somebody sent me a little bible thing,
said the dinosaurs are called behemoths in the Bible and about Outer Space
Aliens,
ships,
uh,
spaceships abductions is talks,
talked about in a Ezekiel one,
and these are from in the King James Bible.
Now,
after all these years of trash in the Bible,
I'd have I ever mentioned to you guys that I haven't even read the fucking
thing.
Oh,
I've tried.
I've tried to read the thing,
but it's all he said it under you with Evan,
the Fucken,
uh,
Polynesians said to the Persians,
I mean,
I,
I can't,
I can't get through it.
It's like trying to reach straight Shakespeare.
But as far as I remember going to church,
they said,
dad,
uh,
you know,
earth was created in six days.
On the seventh day,
God rested and I created Adam and eve and they were in a,
they were in Eden hanging out.
Right?
Then all of a sudden,
you know,
he lays down some rules.
He says,
Hey,
listen,
you guys are in paradise.
I just don't want you to go over there and eat an apple off of that fucking
tree,
you know?
Is that so god damn hard to not eat a piece of fruit?
Who gives a shit?
It's fruit.
No one wants to eat fruit.
The only people eat fruit or kids whose parents are making a medium.
Okay.
Vegetarians and some 50 year old Wall Street guy who just suffered his third
heart attack.
Then maybe a love of fucking apple so he doesn't die.
But other than that,
how easy is it not to eat an apple?
Right?
But Eve,
this stupid fucking whore that she is,
you know you're not going to tell me a key.
I can't do something.
And because she's abroad and you can't punch her in the face,
what does she have to worry about?
Huh?
Who?
Who the fuck is this God guy to tell me I can't go and have an apple?
So what does she do?
She marches right over there with their pubic hair blowing in the fucking wind.
Cause there's no shame at this point because there's been no sin.
Everything's great.
You can walk around and go pet a cheetah.
It doesn't immediately,
or a leopard.
It doesn't immediately grab you by the throat,
fucking snap your neck and then drag you up in a tree so the lions can't get to
it.
Or somebody else may be a fucking baboo,
you know,
with it's psycho goddamn teeth.
Dino,
let's one of the,
one of the fucking major,
uh,
adversaries for a leper is a fucking baboons.
I never knew that shit.
They got those giant teeth who would have known,
you know,
very agile,
left to right sort of movement,
like a water bug,
these insane things.
But Hey,
let's get back to the Bible as far as I remember it,
right.
So they go z,
you know,
walking up to the fucking apple tree,
like some one of those fic Toria secret whores walking down the first fucking
runway.
Although she's not wearing heels,
she just walked in and she never steps on a Brock.
Doesn't step on some glass from a broken millo light bottle cause she's in
paradise.
She walks right over there and some snake starts.
Yet that's what happened.
Some snakes starts yapping in arrear,
right?
Like some Douche on Facebook.
Who finds your wife and her semi-hard pictures starts emailing her,
right?
Worman his way into the relationship,
So this whore goes up and what does she do?
She reaches up and she takes a bite of fruit.
She eats an apple as far as I've been told,
part of this nutritious breakfast,
part of a balanced diet sheets.
A fucking apple.
Maybe she wanted to be regular,
right?
So she'd see apple and then God goes,
what the bitch?
What the fuck did I t I am the one thing I say not to do.
And you got to go do it.
Go Yourself.
That's the end of paradise.
And next thing you know,
she's putting a leaf over a fucking clam.
All right?
Adam's over there.
He didn't do ship.
And evidently he gets punished too because it's religion,
you know,
the punishment never has to make sense.
It just has to be really fucking scary.
So now they're both fucked.
Now all of a sudden the leopards want to fucking take a bite out of their ass,
so they got to get sharpened.
Sticks and all this type of shit,
right?
Then according to the Bible,
all of this that happened like fucking a couple of hundred thousand years ago
and then one day some narratives not getting pussy.
He's so fucking hard up.
He just starts digging in the ground.
You know he's got all that sexual frustration.
He just keeps digging in the ground and one day finds these dinosaur bones that
are way fucking older than the Adam and Eve story.
So it kind of kills the whole goddamn thing.
Now that is far as I know is the story in the Bible,
how the Bible goes down and that's why people on the science side question the
Bible.
Like I said,
I haven't read it.
All right,
so people who've read it,
can you give me the cheat notes?
Are You Bible thumpers out there?
We think the Bible is the best book ever fucking written
aside from the fact that when it was written,
they still thought the fucking world was flat.
They thought if you were gay,
you give,
you go to hell and all that other intolerant horseshit in there.
But you know,
I never read the fucking thing.
So you know,
let me know.
Cause this guy's trying to reclaim,
trying to acclaim,
trying to claim that they address dinosaurs in the Bible,
calling them behemoths,
which is amazing considering we never discovered the fucking bones until after
the book was written.
So how does that work?
Huh?
Was that when God was a burning Bush and all the fish was coming out of the
basket and he just sort of muttered something about behemoths and nobody
understood it,
but it was God.
So they just wrote it down anyways.
Is that what you're going to claim?
Oh Jesus.
Oh Gee.
Hey,
um,
who can turn their world on with her tits?
Um,
what did I want to talk about this week?
How about the Bruins,
Bruins making the fucking playoffs?
I'm predicting that the Bruins will once again make it to the eastern conference
finals and then,
uh,
then what's going to happen?
I'll tell you what's going to happen is that they're not going to go any
further.
I Dunno.
I'm just going to say that cause hopefully they'll prove me wrong.
Who knows?
We've got a great goalie.
You know what's scaring me is fucking Carey price up in Montreal has been
playing fantastic.
All right.
And for some reason when the Bruins have a great goalie,
it only gets us so far.
But those sons of bitches up there with Ken Dryden,
Patrick Wall back and fucking 93 when they went on that in plausible run,
one like 19 overtime games,
one of the great runs at winning the Stanley Cup all fucking time.
Um,
who knows?
I don't know.
I think the flyers will beat him.
The flyers never seem to have problem with the Canadians.
Uh,
they don't give a fuck,
right?
They're just going to punch you in the face.
Um,
anyways.
Hey,
listen to this shit.
You know something,
what happened to me twice this week is people just,
they don't hear what the fuck I'm saying.
This is the classic thing.
When you're doing standup comedy,
you stand on stage and you tell a bunch of jokes and everybody laughs.
Everybody's having just a great time.
And then all of a sudden you come around to his subject that touches a little
close to somebody's life and all of a sudden you're not telling jokes anymore.
Now you're making statements.
Well,
Lo and behold,
once again,
this happens.
I don't know if you guys are aware of this,
but my let it go special is now up on Netflix,
the unedited version,
the version that I wanted the world to see.
But that dream was crushed because on comedy central,
they have advertisers and that's how they make their money,
which I respect.
So then,
you know,
they got to cut out some jokes.
They get to start doing the Morse code because they say,
fuck every other word and then Yada,
Yada,
Yada.
But now it's on Netflix.
Now it's on Netflix.
And you can watch that son of a bitch.
Ah,
completely unedited.
So please tell your friends,
please tell your family,
tell some of your enemies.
Um,
so anyways,
so some are some woman evidently watch this.
Watch my special,
my standup comedy special,
the one where I go on and act like an ass.
And I'm telling jokes just to make you laugh,
just to fucking appease my ego.
That's all on doing.
So anyways,
this lady starts off and uh,
she says offended by your stay at home mom bit.
She starts off.
Hi.
Obviously I'm a stay at home mom.
Why is that obvious?
Because you said you were offended by my stay at home mom bit.
Why couldn't you be just an uh,
uh,
a supporter of stay at home moms?
Oh,
I'm being a cunt right out of the gate.
Let's read this.
She starts off high.
Obviously I'm a stay at home mom and I love watching standup,
but I couldn't continue watching you based on your bit about stay at home moms.
You know,
I love about it.
It's an hour long special and I think I opened with that joke or it was
literally within the first five minutes and she had to shut it off.
She says,
I'm really sorry you feel that way about stay at home moms.
That's one of my pet peeves is when someone's about ready to take the piss out
of me.
I hate when they apologize.
Okay.
You're not sorry.
You're not sorry that I feel that way.
You fucking hate me because I feel that way.
All right.
Stop apologizing.
Oh God.
My voice is cracking.
Stop apologizing.
All right.
Um,
anyway,
she goes and the uh,
blah blah blah blah blah.
If it weren't for us,
there would be no one to drill holes and to do all the other important jobs that
you mentioned.
All right?
If it weren't for you,
what do you just fucking meditate and you make a person
you self centered fucking whore.
Can you believe she just took credit for the creation of babies?
100% credit.
What about the guy who fucking sticks it in Ya?
Huh?
Oh am getting close.
Aw.
What about that part of it?
But there was his son Harry sweaty man
pounding away at your fucking womanhood to completion.
I might add a number of times during the course of a month,
two months,
possibly three months if you got,
you know,
if he got some sort of issue down there for some reason your year there.
The,
I dunno what the fuck.
I never tried to do it,
but I know,
yeah,
we're having a difficult time.
We're trying to get pregnant,
but we're having a difficult time.
It's not the fucking part.
It's the impregnation part.
She's just totally taking away all of that.
That evidently did.
She just sits there and all of a sudden she's pregnant.
Kind of like dead chicken.
The Bible hanging out with that fucking hippie bomb,
Joseph.
Right?
He's sitting over in the corner with his vaporizer.
Hey Man,
I noticed it looks like you're putting on weight,
man.
You gotta lay us off the Dirito if man.
Right.
And all of a sudden she's fucking pregnant.
So evidently this broad,
she's taking full credit,
full credit for getting pregnant.
Completely ignoring the man's part of it.
Show up,
getting close.
Oh,
that's,
that's the noise I make when I climb x.
By the way,
I make a,
I,
I announced to the female and a really high pitch voice,
sort of whiny voice and getting close,
and then I put my mouth right next to her ear and I go,
oh,
that's how it goes down in my world.
Um,
some of the most Sophomore Kuma humor I've ever done.
And right now there's a bunch of guys laughing and as a bunch of females with
their nose all wrinkled that this,
this is what you listen to.
This is what you think is funny.
Yes,
bitch,
this is what I think's funny.
Why don't you go back out in the kitchen and finish making potato salad?
All right.
The fourth of July's coming up.
Um,
I made no sense.
Okay.
Um,
and if it weren't for us,
there would be no one drilling holes into all the other important jobs that you
mentioned.
I didn't say they were important.
I didn't say those jobs were important.
You didn't even listen to the bit.
Let me continue reading here.
I said,
Oprah said that being a mother is the most difficult job in the planet.
If said,
it's the most important job,
I would've gone with her.
But she said it was the most difficult job.
That's that right.
There was the seed of the bit that I created.
Okay.
Just like you creating the fucking kid.
But I don't feel like I created the joke on my own.
It took Oprah to say to,
to,
to plant the seed rule by saying,
by saying that it was the most difficult job on the planet.
All right.
That was her climaxing into my joke.
Pussy.
Oh,
that's disgusting.
Anyways,
so now I think everybody's wrinkle in their nose.
So here we go.
So she continues after not even hearing what I'm saying and she said,
and the reason you stay in your pajamas all day,
that was a line I said,
talking about women is because you don't have one minute to change.
Try taking a shower and putting on on clothes and clothes on with children's
screaming and crying at the shower door.
It's 24,
seven.
It never stops.
Uh,
you don't click a time card.
You never get off work.
It's 24,
seven.
You have absolutely no idea until you're in it.
I made a lot of money in my career before motherhood,
motherhood.
I earned my MBA and other degrees.
I've lived and worked abroad.
Motherhood is the hardest job I've ever done.
I've never said it's,
I've never said it's not the hardest job that you've ever done.
Okay.
All right.
But I'm willing to bet that you've never done a job harder than working on a
fucking oil rig in the middle of the ocean.
All right,
sweetheart,
being a mom is not more difficult than working on an oil rig in the middle of
the fucking ocean.
How about that guy out there who worked on one and it fucking blew up?
He's got second degree burns on his back.
If they're going to turn into third degree burns and then he's eventually going
to explode into flames.
So his only option is to jump basically the equivalent of a three story
building.
He jumps off it
okay
with his rob burned up back into the salt water of the ocean
also now covered in oil.
He's covered in oil with second degree burns in salt water.
Okay.
He can barely fucking breathe.
The fucking ocean is catching on fire because of the oil that's on the surface
of the water.
He has to swim out of that,
get out into the ocean but not get too far away.
Cause he wants to get rescued now he's got to sit there treading water,
hoping he doesn't get eaten alive by sharks or drown
or die.
I Dunno what else.
While he waits for the Coast Guard to come and pick them up,
now you tell me all the mothers out there.
I want you to explain to me a day that was more difficult than that.
And not only that,
all this woman is doing is talking about the negative aspects of being a mother.
She's not talking about how rewarding it is.
You don't get unconditional love from a fucking oil rig.
It's not going to be sitting there at your deathbed,
holding your fucking hand telling you that you know the oil rig is everything it
is today because of you as a person.
Give me a fucking break.
All right?
And also you made the choice to become a mother by letting that guy get on top
of you.
Oh,
getting close,
right?
Typical fucking broad.
You're fucking idea.
She got,
anyway,
she continues.
Your joke is so offensive and so totally wrong.
It's disgusting.
Another thing,
this is precious time to me.
In the evening.
Well,
I didn't fucking ask you to email me.
Good Lord.
What a fuck she,
this is a mother.
Look at her working with the guilt.
This is precious time to me.
In the evening you are watching a stand up special that was going to take a
whole fucking hour.
You shut it off.
Seven minutes into it.
That gives you an extra 53 minutes to write two paragraphs.
They're so full of shit.
So anyways,
it's now she's trying to make me feel guilty like I'm taken away from her
fucking day.
I know the thing.
This is precious time to me in the evening when I can be taking a shower,
read or watch a show and recharge for the next day.
Wait a minute.
You just told me that being a mom was a 24 seven job.
It never stops.
It never ends.
Here you are chilling out,
wanting to take a shower,
read or watch a show and recharge for the next day.
Jesus Christ.
She goes,
oh,
maybe later tonight when one of my children get up,
I'm not on Facebook.
I don't waste any time on the computer and I don't complain about things,
but this was so offensive that I made time for this email.
I'll thank you.
Thank you for taking time out of your day.
You're unbelievably 24 seven day and you just had to say something then this is,
this is awesome.
She,
this is how she answered email.
She says,
very disappointed,
Jamie.
Oh,
actually I never named names.
Okay,
so this is what I love about this.
This woman is obviously going to be a great mom,
okay?
She's dedicated to what?
She's walked away from her Mba career and all that type of shit so she can focus
on her career.
Okay?
But what you can see here is the resentment that's already building because
she's already throwing out guilt onto everybody.
That's what I love about mothers.
All right?
No one told you to become a mother.
You made that fucking choice and now you actually have like resentment for your
fucking job and you're starting to put it on your kids.
I can tell you're already putting it on your kids because you're trying to it on
me.
You try to make me feel guilty that you took the time to send me a fucking I
email.
I didn't ask you to send me your fucking email and then you end it with very
disappointed like I'm looking for your approval.
See you're already getting your God complex cause your fucking kids are looking
at you like you know every God damn answer on the planet,
which you don't.
Jesus Christ.
So there they,
there you go.
There you go.
People,
there it is in a nutshell.
That's what it's like to be a standup comedian.
You make one fucking joke.
Okay.
About an overstatement that someone said that being a mother's the most
difficult job on the planet.
So what does that,
that makes me think about all these other jobs digging for coal.
You now being president of the United States and having this haven't decide that
we're going to go to war and then you've got to lay to bed,
go lay in bed knowing that a bunch of people are now going to die.
Babies,
women,
you know,
18 to 21 year old fucking people who signed up right out,
out,
out a God damn high school to be in the army,
marines,
Navy.
You've got it.
You're gonna make that.
You've got to lay in bed,
try and get fucking eight hours sleep with that shit weighing on your head.
You know
that that was a joke.
It's not the most difficult job in the planet.
If you said it's the most important,
I would've gone with that.
All right?
I said I was arguing that it wasn't the most difficult.
Okay?
And this is what happens.
People,
they don't hear what you're saying.
And then they go off on another 10 tangent.
Like this other fucking cunt.
This is a guy.
All right,
this guy,
what the fuck did he talk?
Where the hell is it?
Ah,
Jesus.
Bill.
Uh,
Jesus,
look what you did.
You just slowed the whole fucking thing down.
Um,
oh,
I disagree.
He said bill loved the podcast,
but I disagree with you on the whole music downloading thing.
Most of my music that I have that I have is not bought for good reason.
First of all,
the last two CD's I bought brand new from the store is skipped in multiple CD
players right out of the box.
Secondly,
artists only get about five to 10% five to 10 cents per CD,
which in the grand scheme of things,
doesn't add up to much compared to the money they get from tee shirts and gigs.
Now,
don't get me wrong,
the people that just download thousands of CD's worth of stuff and never go to
shows there.
The douche bags,
I tried to go to at least five shows a year.
Wow.
And I go to Lollapalooza in Chicago once every three years.
So Am I a to you built?
No,
you're not a loser.
You're just stealing music.
You're stealing fucking music and you're trying to shine it all up.
Like,
Hey man,
the artist doesn't make any fucking money.
You bought two cds from the store and they skipped in multiple places.
Dude,
you can go to iTunes and you can download music in a digital form and that
doesn't skip all right.
You're trying to justify the fact that you still thousands and thousands of
dollars worth of fucking music.
And then you spent,
you know,
a couple hundred bucks
on concert tickets and tee shirts and shit.
And then,
and there you go.
Yeah,
I didn't steal a hundred percent for you.
I completely disagree with you.
I'm not saying you're a loser.
I'm saying you're a thief.
You're stealing and you know you're stealing.
All right.
I'm not a musician do it.
I bought cds.
I bought those things.
I know they start to skip,
but if I buy,
am I fucking upload them onto my,
my computer.
But I,
I do all of my shit through iTunes.
But,
uh,
I don't,
I don't steal music.
And when I did steal it,
I addressed the fact that I was stealing music.
I wasn't saying that I wasn't part of the fucking problem.
Back in the day when it first came out,
my eyes fucking dropped out of my head to free music.
And I went to limewire and I downloaded a couple of hundred fucking songs.
But in the end when people presented the argument,
dude,
just stay [inaudible].
I couldn't get around it.
I was like,
yeah,
you're right.
I am.
So I stopped.
So I'm not saying I'm better than you and I'm not saying you're a fucking loser.
What I'm saying is your steel at fucking music,
however you frame it and go into a couple of concerts,
doesn't make up for the fact that you stole the music.
You know,
it's like concert tickets cost money.
It's like a concert ticket was free and you made a donation.
You still got something out of your money,
you got a tee shirt and you got a fucking concert tickets.
So you're,
you're acting like those monies make up for the fact that you stole music.
Like you didn't get anything out of the,
out of,
out of the concert ticket and putting down money for a t shirt.
You got to fucking rock show or hip hop show,
whatever the fuck you went to and you got a t shirt that doesn't make up for the
fact that you stole the fucking music.
It doesn't.
All right.
So like I said,
I'm not saying you were losing your fucking thief.
Oh,
I'm on my God damn high horse here.
Um,
let's get to underrated overrated here.
People,
uh,
a topic that I thought was dying that I'm actually pleased to say is a,
is making a comeback.
Oh,
before I do that,
I mentioned a few weeks ago that,
um,
the short film cheat that me,
Joe de Rosa and Robert Kelly,
uh,
wrote and acted in and Joe de Rosa did a phenomenal job directing this movie,
the short film.
We got it into the Tribeca film festival,
which is one of the biggest film festivals out there.
It's right up there with Sundance and all that type of stuff.
Um,
and I wanted to give you guys to screening times.
If you're actually in the,
uh,
New York area and you want to come down and support our film,
we would love to see you down there.
We're going to try to hang out as,
as,
as many screenings as we possibly can.
There's a couple of them that we're not allowed to go to just because this is
going to be industry there and they want to review the film and you know,
we can't be breathing down their necks,
making them uncomfortable.
So here are the screening times,
uh,
Saturday,
April 23rd at 7:00 PM is the first screening.
Of course,
I don't have where the screening,
I'm such a fucking idiot.
I'll give you this information.
I'll just tell you one of the,
this Saturday at 7:00 PM Wednesday at 5:30 PM,
that's April 27th and Saturday,
April 30th at 4:00 PM and Sunday May 1st at 7:30 PM.
Um,
I believe I'm calling in the opiod Anthony show this week,
I believe Thursday this week,
uh,
to Rosa and Bobby Kelly are going to be on there and we're going to have all the
rest of the information.
So I'm,
I what an idiot I am.
Why am I such a fucking moron?
You know,
I'd go to the MM podcast.com we'll it,
we'll have the actual,
the official fan page,
by the way.
And he gets all the shit right.
I'm such a fucking more,
I was so excited to tell you guys all that type of shit.
And what did I do?
What did I do?
I fucked the whole thing up.
All right.
You feel that?
Do you hear that silence?
The podcast has just screeched to a grinding halt and it's 100% my fault.
Alright.
Underrated.
Overrated for this week.
All right.
Underrated.
This guy says ice cream sandwiches.
Uh,
they are made from the cheapest ice cream and the crappiest cookies,
but they are fucking delicious and I can eat like five.
Um,
I actually had a debate with Nia on this one.
MMM.
I thought he was literally talking about ice cream sandwiches,
but she's saying because he said cookies.
He means those ones that have like the chocolate chip cookies and with that jet,
that generic ice cream in the middle,
it's basically,
you know,
the filling that they put in hot dogs.
It's the ice cream version of that.
And he said he can eat like five and a,
I am right there with Ya.
I'm right there with you.
I think I could eat,
I think I could eat six,
but I would get sick,
but I could eat five just like you and I would not be sick and my body at no
point would be acting like what I was doing was incorrect until about,
uh,
15 minutes later when I suddenly would have to take a nap.
You eat really bad food and you have to take a nap.
Um,
you get all sleepy or as black people call it the Itis,
you get the itis.
I told you that story a long time ago,
didn't I?
I'll tell the tea again.
The fuck I got an hour to kill here.
I know I got some new listeners.
Um,
I,
back in the day when I was on the,
uh,
the Chappelle show tour and it was me,
Charlie Murphy and uh,
Don Rawlings who played ashy Larry,
we went out in 2004,
mid 2004 and toured.
I toured,
I stayed on the tour till about the end of February,
2005.
And,
uh,
these guys used to break my balls about my shirts,
all my clothes and all that type of shit.
That actually turned into a bit when I did my half hour special,
that whole bit,
that Ma,
this motherfucker only has five shirts that came from hanging out with those
guys doing talent shows back in the day.
Drew Frazier and all those guys,
Rob Stapleton.
Uh,
well the room did,
I used to do Capone's roams,
all those things when I used to jump back and forth between the black rooms,
white rooms for mainstream rooms,
that uptown rooms as they used to call him.
But anyways,
so these guys used to,
you know,
thanks,
you just give me shit and that type of stuff.
So we had gone out drinking or I had gone out drinking.
I was brutally fucking hung over and I just didn't want to listen to this shit.
And we were driving from Chicago up to Vernon hills to do a,
the Zane,
he's up there and it was a good hour,
hour and a half drive.
I don't know what,
but it's going to seem like five hours.
And I could tell that they were just going to be fucking on my shit because I
was really hung over.
So what I did was I asked the,
I don't know,
somehow I came,
I walked out to try and get some fresh air and I saw that there was a Popeye's
chicken,
like fucking two blocks up.
So I ran up there and got like a fucking,
I don't know,
a 17 piece of that shit with biscuits and all of that ship.
We will leave and right around 11 and we go and we get in the fucking limo to go
up there and I bring,
hey guys,
they got us some food and I ate one piece and watch them devour like another
five,
six pieces,
a couple of biscuits.
Right?
And they were already giving me Shit and within fucking 15 minutes they were
fucking sound asleep.
And I just sat there with a smile on my face with some of that greasy food,
my stomach,
but not enough to make me fall asleep.
Just enough to feel comfort,
comfort it.
Right.
And I had my sunglasses on and I cruised,
although we cruise all the way up there and they slept the whole fucking way.
It's one of the brilliant moves and my standup career.
Um,
so anyways,
I'll speak into that shit.
I'm actually get myself into great shape here.
You want to know how I've been doing it?
Well,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm going to tell you anyway.
A A,
I mentioned back in the day I got a juicer and uh,
like most things,
you know,
when you get something new,
you're all about it.
You're all about it for like,
I don't know what,
right.
A week,
two weeks,
maybe a month.
And then one day you just blow it off.
You just fucking blow it off and then it starts gathering dust.
And then every once in awhile you,
you just look at whatever you bought your Ipad,
your fucking,
I don't know what your,
whatever gadget you're hand is just over there collecting dust and you just had
that feeling like,
God,
I used to be so fucking into that thing.
You know,
it's kind of like a relationship.
you meet some hot girl,
you're telling your friends do this is fucking cigs I've ever been with you.
She's got like the perfect hits you ever do that you start describing a body to
all your fucking animal guy friends and then all of a sudden it turns into our
relationship,
you know?
And now it's your girlfriend and now you know,
I described the text to my friends or the fucking crazy thing,
she didn't bed,
you know?
And then what happens?
You're totally into,
or your bank in your bag and your bag in and then just one day you don't even
notice,
you're just not into it anymore.
Yeah.
Oh,
and then one day you're walking by and you look down at your pussy just
gathering dust,
like you fucking laser disc player and you're wondering what the fuck happened.
You know?
And that's the moment where you realize if you're with the right person or not.
Because if you decide that you're going to work at the relationship and get the
sparks going again,
you're with the right person.
But if you're just looking at it like a fucking old VCR.
Yeah,
no,
it's a,
it's time to move on.
That's what I think.
So anyways,
let's get back to the juicer.
Everybody.
So the Josar
evidently is a my fucking gadgets soulmate because I looked at it and I was
getting sad going,
you know what?
Like I got a fucking,
uh,
I got to get this thing back in my life.
I've got to find where,
where,
where did we lose the magic?
So I went to the health foods
and I went in there like a little fucking,
you know,
Vegan.
I fucking go in there,
right?
Oh,
you know what's funny,
this,
this displace right around the corner from where I live,
cells that coconut water that I absolutely love that I drank on Joe Rogan's show
and that they told me they got on amazon.com and I ordered it on amazon.com you
know me,
I'm totally fucking,
I got the OCD like,
or whatever.
I,
when I get into shit,
I get into shit and it was like 20 something bucks to get like,
like 12 of these things.
So it was already expensive.
And then you know,
if,
if you know,
you just do five to six business days,
who gives a fuck?
They charge you like three bucks.
But I was like,
no,
I want that shit in two days.
So my shipping cost was as much as the goddamn price of the coconut.
I paid like 40 bucks for 12 of them and then I go down the street went out when
I reintroduced myself to my juicer going,
hey baby,
let's,
you know what happened to us,
man.
Let's watch a movie tonight,
right?
I go over to the fucking a vegetable place.
Oh,
you know what?
That creepy little analogy just reminded me of I guess to some fucking show out
there where people are in love with inanimate objects,
like they actually like fuck offense or a bridge or they want to like marry the
Eiffel Tower.
Can somebody please tell me what that show is?
I,
I really want to watch that because I saw that one that was fatal,
fatal attractions where people have wild animals that they try to turn to try to
turn into a,
they tried to turn into pets and those people were just so fucking stupid of me
that I couldn't watch the show.
But I ended up hearing that that show was good because they get,
they get into the psychology of,
of why somebody gets into that.
All I saw when I saw that guy with the buffalo walking around his house and
every time he walked by him that buffalo would slam him into the wall and he
looked like Wayne Gretzky getting fucking checked by sort of fucking normal size
hockey player and you'd just be like,
oh,
is he would walk by now she just play and she just playing and shit.
It was so fucking stupid.
I,
I couldn't watch it.
So,
um,
anybody can tell me what the name of that show is,
where people are like in love with like a door,
you know,
dude,
how much alone time are you spending?
I mean,
I haven't heard that in jail.
Well,
he in solitary confinement,
you get love with the walls.
I bet you do.
At some point,
some point you just,
you just from just lack of human contact,
you know that man brain kicks in where you get visually stimulated,
you've got to get visually stimulated by something and they would just be like,
I bet it's like at some point during the day when the sun starts going down
right in the shadow just hits the wall a certain way and he just,
there you are.
There you are.
You sweet little naughty,
naughty piece of plaster.
Ah,
where you been for the last 23 hours?
I should,
I don't want to hear it.
You know,
so fucking creepy.
Actually.
Somebody who's probably in jail or has been a jail is going to be oh man.
Actually when you're in solitary confinement there's no sunlight.
Ah,
right.
Whatever.
Whatever the fuck it is.
You fuck the floor,
you know,
there you go.
Is that any prison book?
I think I hit my low point when I was consistently fucking the floor.
Um,
all right,
let's continue on here.
So anyways,
so I've got my juicer back in my life.
That's what the fuck I'm trying to tell you.
So I go to the Goddamn health food store,
right?
And you don't have to worry about going to the health food stores,
even though the aisles are really skinny,
much skinnier.
Then one of the,
uh,
grocery stores,
those fucking,
you know,
people who actually eat healthy or are there just waif human beings.
They do yoga,
little wispy Lily,
lily knows dogs little whippets.
They just like them,
you know,
walking up and down the aisles with their fucking tail,
between their legs trying to pick out Zucchini.
So I'm going in there right suddenly feeling like I'm on roids cause I look so
much bigger app full of Shit.
There was a couple of decent size people in there,
but whatever.
So I go in there,
I pick out all this fucking,
uh,
fruits and vegetables to juice.
So that's,
I've been starting my day.
People start my day,
I fucking juice.
Then I go get my fucking pit bull.
We go for a walk,
we go for a hike for like an hour.
I come back and then I have a bowl of oatmeal with some,
a handful of raisins thrown in there.
That's how I start my day.
And it's been fucking great for me.
I'm not trying to preach to you people,
I'm not trying to be a fucking breakfast Nazi here.
But this is what I realized with me.
This is how I get out of whack,
is if I start my day either with,
um,
I can't even just say toast and eggs,
but if I,
if I throw the Bacon in there,
then it's really extra salty.
Then I got to throw a little jam on my toast,
you know,
to try to level myself,
just like a fucking cocaine drinking alcohol to bring me down a little bit.
You know,
I got the salt salt's making me sleepy,
so I put the jelly on the toast to bring me back up right there.
I'm out of fucking whack.
Or if I have French toast or anything you put syrup on there,
my sugar goes through the roof.
Next thing you know,
I'm grabbing a handful of fucking potato chips,
you know,
like an hour later.
And then like for the rest of the day,
my blood sugar,
I don't know what it is.
It probably looks like a,
uh,
what do you got?
One of the,
one of those things where there Duh,
Duh,
Duh.
The heart thing,
Sonogram,
whatever the fuck you call it.
Not a telegraph.
What do you call that fucking thing?
You know when,
when,
when you're,
when you're laying there in the hospital
and there they are looking at your heart rate.
That's what,
that's what it looks like.
Salt,
sugar,
salt,
sugar.
That's what I do for the rest of the fucking day.
And then at the end of the day,
I take a big piece of cake and I shove it right down my fucking pie hole.
And that's my day.
And then gradually my white doughy stomach starts to hang over my belt and then
I hate myself and then I start lashing out of people in the crowd.
So there you go.
That's what's been working for me.
Um,
so when and why don't you guys give it a shot if you want to,
if you don't,
I don't give a fuck.
Oh by the way,
hundred and 70 days without booze.
And I actually fucked it up yesterday.
I was at a party or a barbecue yesterday and I accidentally twice had two sips
of beer.
Okay.
So tactically in my world,
my streak is still going because it was an accident.
But I,
I've,
I've had booze within the last 24 hours and this is,
this is what I've noticed,
which is really fascinating about the human brain.
And I didn't realize this till I went to Stockholm,
Sweden,
when I did that Gig over there,
remember I told you that story and I went over there and everybody,
you know,
and I forgot that,
I didn't speak a word of Swedish and everyone's gone tries and tries and cars
your hydrogen.
And I was,
you know,
the fucking,
the comedian in front of me who was speaking English backstage went out there
and did his whole act and Swedish and was killing
[inaudible] Rjr RJ to hygiene and the crowds like,
wow.
And I'm freaking out going,
are they even going to fucking understand me?
This is what I learned when I was in Sweden was I took for granted how much I
don't read when I'm in the states because I you just like,
I think when you look at a stop sign you don't read stop,
you just,
you just visually looking at it and I didn't realize that shit until I went over
to Sweden and the amount of extra thinking that I had to do where I would be
looking at like a car and just be like,
okay,
is that a taxi or is that a police car?
You know?
Or I,
I'd have to look at a storefront and just sort of try to,
cause I can't read the word,
it's in Swedish and it's like 97 fucking letters.
I'd have to just really sit there looking as a close.
Is there,
is there food in there?
Is that,
what the fuck is that?
That's what happened to me
at the party.
I opened the refrigerator door and I saw this green can and I immediately
equated it with soda and I,
and in my brain told me it was a sprite,
turned out it was seven up and right next to it was a red and white can.
So I think,
I actually think it was just red.
So in my world that was coke.
So I reached for the coke,
opened it up,
took a sip of it thinking I was drinking coca cola and it was a Mexican beer and
I drank it and I didn't even record.
I don't know,
it was a weird tasting beer.
I thought it was like iced tea.
And I looked down and I'm reading it,
you know,
and I actually,
I'm just looking for coke and I'm looking all over the words.
And finally I see beer.
I'm like,
is this,
did I just drink a beer?
I was like,
fuck,
there goes my goddamn streak.
So of course he is laughing at me.
So then I go over and grab what I thought was a sprite was actually seven up.
I started drinking that and then later on the piano at the party,
you grabbed the wrong thing.
Once again,
I thought I was drinking coke
and I reached over and I grabbed it and another thing,
now the fucking swig of beer.
So I want you guys to know is my streak over,
you know all you addicts out there.
What does that mean?
If you,
if you do that,
if you're an AA,
do you have to turn in your chip and start all over again and go up there and
cry at the podium because you actually had a sip of beer?
Do I get any credit with the fact that I,
that I opened the bear,
took the sip of the bear and just said,
oh fuck,
this is,
you know,
I thought this was coke.
It's a bear and I just set it down.
I didn't have any more anybody,
can you help me out here?
This is when I wish I took callers.
I'm glad I don't take college because I think college really slowed down the
fucking show.
You know,
half of them are fucking prank phone calls and then half the people,
it just takes them too.
God Damn Long.
Plus I like talking.
All right.
You haven't noticed the fact that I rarely have a guest on this show and I could
somehow keep it going for a fucking hour.
You know,
that's not an amazing ability.
That's,
that is an incredible personality.
Fluff.
All right.
Um,
more um,
underrated.
Overrated.
A unpaid internships.
I graduated from college less than a year ago and had been looking for a job in
my area of studies for more than a year with no success.
Dude.
I,
my heart goes out to these fucking kids just getting out to out of college right
now in the,
one of the worst economies ever.
It's just fucking ridiculous.
They already overcharged your for your fucking education and these goddamn
bankers screwed the whole fucking economy up.
Anyways,
plumbing ahead.
He says,
while looking for a job,
I encountered numerous agencies that offer internships,
but no,
but none for PE it seems.
How is that legal by the way?
You don't pay him anything.
It seems like many places.
Take advantages of the bad economy and the desperate job seekers to lure them
into doing work for free.
Unfortunately,
I'm one of them.
Dude.
What kind of a fucking,
this is what,
you know,
I want to go undercover into corporate America and I want it.
I want to see how that goes down.
How that,
how,
like is it just like the mob we like age,
not fucking personal,
it's business.
Oh,
you know.
Well,
if you,
if you check out the market,
what the market will bear now is,
uh,
it's advantageous if you're the employer to not,
to take advantage of the human resources and offer them a,
a negative cashflow contract.
However they fucking deal.
They never just come out and said,
hey,
let's take advantage of the future and pay them absolutely nothing.
So we can,
we can drive,
we can put rims on our,
our,
our flashy fucking cars.
Um,
anyways,
he says,
uh,
what do these agencies offer in exchange experience?
Building your resume,
making connections with other employees,
promises of hiring after a short period and other bullshit like that.
He says,
fuck that.
And capital letters you mentioned in Joe Rogan's podcast,
how comedians should not offer their material for free in exchange for exposure.
And I completely agree.
These unpaid internships that are so popular right now need to stop.
I'm more efficient than some of my fulltime coworkers at my internships,
which are not a surprise.
Oh wait,
which are not a surprise,
are part of a worker's Union.
And I work,
AH,
here comes my bed reading skills.
I got totally confused with his parentheses.
MMM.
He says,
and I worked there only two days out of the week.
It wasn't funny.
It would be sad.
So he's basically saying in those two days,
he does more work than the people who are members of the union.
You know,
that's something that unions have to address here is I'm all about unions.
But you know,
just because you now have the power to lean on a shovel doesn't mean you should.
And that's what's really fucked over.
Unions.
Unions were a great idea and people died,
had their heads kicked in,
got shot at by our own fucking army.
When guys like Andrew Carnegie had the connections to bring them in like he did
there and the fucking bags of the Allegheny out there in Pittsburgh or wherever
the fuck it was at,
that's now a mall.
All right?
They needed those unions so we could avoid sweatshop,
the sweatshop labor conditions that existed in this country.
And then what happened aside from the map,
the mob taken over those things.
What happened is his guys use the unions,
the power of unions as a way to get over fucking paid and not to bust their ass
at work anymore.
So then they became the exact fucking thing that they were rebelling against.
So I understand why corporations move there.
They're fucking,
um,
companies out of this country.
I also understand why that there had to be unions.
As you know,
this is what it always comes down to is people are people rich.
People aren't the only greedy fucking assholes out there.
It,
you know,
middle class and poor people.
If you put them in a position where they can be greedy.
The sad thing is most people will take advantage of this situation.
This is not these,
and these are not unique theories.
This is the overall theory,
Harsh Siri that most people learn when they,
when they get out of their house and they get into the real world,
you realize that most people are cons.
There's very few good people out there,
poor middle class or fucking rich,
this very few people that will actually do the right thing.
So,
uh,
I 100% agree with that.
It would be,
you know,
speaking of unions,
it would be great if you could somehow start one.
You know,
that's what she needs to do is you need to get everybody on the same page and
say,
listen,
we're not saying you got to give us all of us,
but this fucking working for free is ridiculous.
Um,
yeah,
they're totally taken advantage of you,
um,
because of the market.
But I guess if it's a good market,
you guys can take advantage of them.
I don't know,
man.
It's just so,
I don't know who the fuck knows,
but I definitely that there's just something wrong with having kids work for
fucking free.
All right.
And I will say to people who were in unions,
which I am 100 supportive in support of you motherfuckers need to work harder
and you'll have a better,
um,
you'll have a better public image.
Now I'm not saying everybody in unions,
don't,
you know,
they all have them lean on shovels,
but you know why you got that reputation.
Okay,
I'm Irish.
I know we got why we got the reputation for being a bunch of drunk motherfuckers
because so many of us are,
or at least enough of us got so fucking drunk that we completely wiped out any
sort of good Irishman out there.
Alright,
so there you go.
Oh,
another one.
Documentaries.
Underrated.
In the last few months,
I've become a big fan of documentaries,
especially about Co,
uh,
are corrupted economy,
are fucked up culture in our diet,
a dying planet and environment.
I have to say these films put a really great picture as far as our civilization
goes.
Yeah,
I know.
That's why I kind of stopped watching them.
I just try to do the right thing in my own life.
If I,
if I watch too many of those,
they really depressed the shit out of me.
MMM.
The president has already looking bad and I did not see a way we can dig
ourselves out of this hole that we've created.
I just don't understand why people dismiss these types of films.
Are they trying to avoid the painful truth?
Absolutely.
I just said I was,
are they in denial?
Absolutely.
There are ways and solutions to fix it,
but as long as we have,
uh,
democrats versus Republicans,
white versus blacks versus versus Spanish coal and oil energy verse,
uh,
Clean Energy and most importantly fucking paper money and stock markets,
nothing's going to change.
Yeah.
This guy,
this is,
this is exact conclusion that I came.
Um,
although I don't agree that a lot of the clean energy they say is clean energy.
Like as much as I drive a hybrid,
which is really a scam,
it's only an electric car when it's going five miles an hour under.
Other than that,
it's just an underpowered gas car,
but it does burn clean and it does get great gas mileage.
But you know,
electric cars,
I mean those batteries eventually you have to dispose of those.
And those things wreak havoc.
Basically,
human beings in general wreak havoc on the environment.
So I think the solution is you have to have some sort of population control and
they should do it sooner rather than later because if they did it sooner,
we could avoid some sort of style on s slash Hitler solution because that's what
the fuck they're going to do.
Um,
I think the problem with human beings is we treat global problems the same way
are a college kid treats doing a term paper.
We do it the night before.
You know,
remember y two K we knew that shit was coming and ended up not being a fucking
problem,
but everybody panicked in the final two months.
They were talking about it for 10 years that we were going to have this possibly
have this fucking problem.
And we waited until the last fucking second.
And I think that the population problems going to be the same thing.
The problem is too many fucking people.
There's no,
there's nothing wrong with chopping down trees.
There's nothing wrong with using coal.
There's nothing wrong with driving a big car.
There's nothing wrong with any of that.
The problem is,
is that the 7 billion people on the fucking planet that,
because that's a problem.
All right?
We need to get that number way the fuck down.
Whey the fuck down.
I would say under a billion
under a billion people,
you need to do that.
So I think that you should just implement laws,
the amount of people that,
uh,
kids that you can have.
And I also think that,
you know,
you should offer people money if they,
to not have kids,
uh,
adopt kids recycle.
I think that they should do all of that type of stuff while they try to have
cleaner burning cars and that type of shit and just gradually let people kind of
die off.
You know,
I,
that's,
that's what I feel.
You know,
cause if you don't do that,
then eventually,
um,
I think that we're going to run out of food,
run out of clean water and you're going to have the rich in their gated
communities and they're going to be guarded by the black water people and that
it's going to be shooting out the rest of us in their fucking heads,
in our heads.
That's,
that's what I think's going to happen personally,
you know,
if mother nature doesn't get his first all right.
That was uplifting.
All right,
let's get to,
uh,
let's get to advice for the week.
Uh,
bill year and a half ago,
um,
where the hell am I?
A year and a half ago,
me and this girl that I used to work with were hanging out a lot and fooling
around all summer.
Very nice.
It was pretty casual.
There you go.
That's how you set it up.
It's pretty casual.
Wonderful.
And I think it just,
the artists trying to keep it there and as I've told you before,
what that is,
it's the,
it's the time between you hooking up.
Okay.
Yeah.
When you keep it a casual and that type of shit.
If you want to hang out and have drinks,
that's fine.
But when you get back to your place,
you do the deed and that's it.
She's got to go.
You can't hang out and watch a movie.
That's when they start getting feelings.
It's not fair to the female,
you know,
that's what you gotta do.
Don't call him all the fucking time.
You got to keep it fucking casual.
All right.
Continuing,
which is kind of hard to do when you work with them.
Um,
but anyways,
he goes,
it was pretty casual,
but that was only because we both knew I had to leave in August,
so we made a point to not get to cert.
Serious.
Beautiful.
Um,
once the summer ended,
I had to go back to school in Miami.
So our situation kind of ended,
but we stayed in touch.
Then recently,
this last spring break,
I went home for 10 days when I let her know I was going to be in town.
She said that,
uh,
that we had to hang out,
but only his friends because she had a boyfriend,
which I was fine with.
All right dude.
Now,
but I haven't read this one yet,
but I gotta tell you right here.
Uh,
don't hang out with them more than once.
All right?
This is what you should do in that situation.
She's got a boyfriend.
It's over.
All right?
So if she wants to hang out,
hang out in a public place,
and at the end of the night you say you gotta go,
don't bring up sex.
Don't fucking do anything like what you used to do.
She's got a boyfriend.
You've got to walk away from that situation.
Not to mention if you,
the two of you are just hanging out at any moment.
Her boyfriend could walk in and you could get the old fucking claddagh ring to
the side of the fucking head.
Uh,
anyways,
so the first day I was there,
she came over to my house to hang out.
Okay,
that's a,
that's a red flag right there.
She's got a boyfriend.
You come to town,
she immediately drops her boyfriend and comes to hang out with you.
All right.
After a half hour of that awkward catching up conversation,
we went up to my room to watch a movie.
Oh Geez.
Yes.
Wants to move.
He started,
she made sure to drive home.
Uh,
the fact that I should make a move on her because she's with someone else.
Yes.
See right here,
dude.
She's playing with your Dick.
She slapping it around,
making it go up and then she's going,
hey,
hey.
We got to take it easy.
And then it goes back down and get,
she's fucking with you.
She fucking with you.
She's playing the up and down game from the OPN.
Anthony Show with your Dick.
If you guys haven't seen that yet,
I'm telling you,
look that up on Youtube,
the opiate Anthony up and down game.
It's one of the most genius bits I've ever seen.
Fucking hilarious.
Um,
anyways,
I completely disregarded this.
Oh,
so she tells you.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Let me get,
let me go back here.
I really have to,
to drop my commentary here.
Why don't I just read the rest here.
Um,
so the movie starts and she drives home the point that they shouldn't,
he should make a move on her because she's,
she is with somebody else.
So he says,
I completely disregard this and I put my arm around her anyways,
10 minutes into the movie.
You know what I respect that move.
By the way,
10 minutes into the movie,
we're in a full on cuddle and she's doing that shit where she's running her
finger up and down my arm.
Then out of nowhere she flips around and climbs on top of me with that.
Fuck me looking arise.
Dude,
this is a great story.
She even,
she's even doing that preset,
slightly heavy breathing dude,
I'm not,
I haven't read this.
I'm telling you she's going to pull the emergency chute.
This is the Richard Pryor bit where they went to your dick is hard enough to cut
diamonds,
I believe is how Richard put it.
Or Mr Pryor.
Let me have some fucking respect here.
Saying Richard,
like I know the guy.
Um,
she drops in to start kissing me but stops in inch from my mouth and stays there
for a second or two.
Then she climbs off and goes back to cuddling.
Ah.
You know,
I do.
You're young.
You didn't know any better,
but if you were older,
you set yourself up for this.
After recollecting myself,
I started to say something,
but the second I started talking,
she flipped over and did it again.
But for a bit longer this time,
this time I asked her what the fuck she was doing and she giggled cunt.
Yeah.
Dude,
right there,
man.
This is the thing.
You got to take charge of the situation.
You got to tell you Dick,
to stand down and be like,
look,
either we're going to do this or we're not going to do this.
This is,
I actually think at that point you should have just bounced around to there and
rubbed one out.
That's the power move right there,
man.
That's the move that's going to make you feel better than if he even fucked her
because she's still going to get something out of it.
She got to get laid right.
So fuck debt.
You should have kicked her out right there and you spend like,
you know what?
This was a bad idea.
Shut this off.
You have to go.
You shouldn't be doing this.
You have a boyfriend.
See,
you flip it around.
You put the guilt on her.
She leaves you fucking rub one out,
right?
Then you don't give a shit that you didn't bang her and then you fucking go out
to the local watering hole.
You know you're going to run into some chick.
You went to fucking high school with your little older.
He little more manly.
You get the scruff going and you fucking tag her and fuck this girl.
She is a con.
She has a boyfriend.
She shouldn't be doing this shit.
All right,
let's continue.
Um,
where the hell was I?
Uh,
this time though,
she stayed,
she did it for about full,
full 30 seconds.
Okay.
So,
so we went back to cuddling for the next five minutes until she did it for a
third time.
This time though,
she stayed there for about 30 seconds and she wouldn't,
and she would pull back every time I actually
kiss her so that she kept the inch between us.
Once she got off,
she started that giggling again,
which by then had gone from Q two annoying as hell and then slipped her shoes on
and said she had to go see dote.
If you took charge and one of those you could have bounced her out.
We didn't hang out again after that.
And now I'm back in Miami.
I guess my question is what should I have done?
I guess I already answered it.
And what the fuck was she doing?
Any answer would be great or even a rant about those annoying teasing cons.
Thanks.
Well,
you know what,
dude,
I hadn't read this one.
I was a busy this weekend.
My,
uh,
the guy who helps me with my podcast who will remain nameless because that's how
I do it,
sent me this thing and I'm a little late today.
So it's the first time I read it.
Um,
yeah,
that's what she was doing.
She just,
I don't know,
you'd almost have to ask a female to get into the psychology of it,
but I could I guess like I think that,
I dunno to,
does she want to just see that you still want to fuck her and that,
like I can tell you this right now that her relationship with this other guy
isn't gonna work and she has made your fucking not major.
She's gay.
She's either really immature or eventually she has major issues and she'll fuck
up every relationship by doing shit like this.
And eventually she's going to be that old hottie hanging out at the wine bar,
you know,
with the crows feet around her eyes,
that check should just send me end up being that girl and then we'll look back
and regret at all the good guys that she fucking,
Dick teased as she was playing the fucking field.
But,
um,
this is what you do in the future.
The second a girl is doing some shit like that.
The second she said,
listen,
just so you know,
I have a boyfriend,
we can't be doing this.
You should have said,
you know what?
You're right.
Let's not watch a movie
and write.
Then you kick her out so you have some sort of power.
All right?
And if you want to fuck a girl like that,
you should have been the one saying no.
You should have been the one pushing her off.
All right?
Because it sounds like she has that fucking thing where you know she gets off on
the fact that you want our but can't have her.
All right?
So if you're acting like you don't want her,
that fucks with her head like,
wait a minute,
what am I losing my pussy power?
And you just literally back your way into the fucking boat.
Then you clubber over their head and then there you go.
You got your fish in the boat.
All right?
That's how you do that.
But I gotta tell you in the future,
do chicks like that?
It just a complete fucking waste of time.
You're already banged her so you're already dotted all the i's crossed all the
t's.
What the fuck you still doing your there because it's an easy,
you thought it was an easy fucking lay when you got back,
which is understandable.
Okay.
But the problem is is you don't have your Dick and check your Dick is running
your fucking life.
You got to make the decisions.
All right?
And when you fucking do that,
you start winning those a lot more.
See,
women have their pussies in check.
That's why they always win those battles 90% of the fucking time.
So there you go.
That's the little information that I can help you with.
What I,
like I said,
don't ever,
don't ever be afraid to fucking ask a female for advice on stuff like that.
Not only will they give you advice,
they actually enjoy doing it and they'll have way better advice than I do
because uh,
you know,
cause they're a fucking woman.
You know what I mean?
It's like he calling me or asking a plumber about fucking carpentry.
Go to a carpenter.
All right.
That is the podcast for this week.
I hope you guys,
uh,
hope you guys enjoyed it.
Seemed like a fairly smooth one.
Right?
Um,
let,
let me,
can I whore out some dates here?
People,
can you hang with me this long enough?
Huh?
Well maybe you're going to hang with me cause you're on final approach.
Oh,
you know what?
I can't stand.
This is what happened me the other day.
I went out to go buy a my fucking water cooler that I want to have just in case
a tsunami hits out here cause I live on a fault line and I always want to have
at least five to 10 gallons of water.
You know,
I'm already inland enough with the tsunamis not going to hit.
If a tsunami hits me here,
I'm telling you,
Utah's in trouble.
All right,
so I go to Lowe's hardware,
I go there online,
I look up to see if they have the one that I want and then,
you know,
and Lowe's has it.
So rather than just saying they only have it online,
I'm assuming it's at the fucking store.
So I jumped in my car and I drive over there and then they don't fucking have
it.
They don't fucking have it.
And it's just,
you know,
just fucking drove me nuts.
So then I stop off at a sporting goods store to buy a pump because my football
doesn't have any air in it.
And this is what you do at 42 when you don't have any fucking kids,
you know,
you actually,
you still acting like you fucking 14 so I dunno,
I just had that moment when I went into the sporting goods store.
You know,
I hate when they can't fucking help me.
I'm asking a simple question and then I start to flip out and then they just
call me sir a million fucking times.
You Know Sarah,
I'm sorry sir.
But sir,
could you sir,
could you please net sharing this year please sir.
Thank you Sarah.
That fucking shit.
That's what reminds me of,
of flying on the plane.
If you do anything,
if you have your seat back,
Syracuse,
could you please put your seat back up,
sir?
Thank you sir.
Syrah in order to expedite this series.
Sir,
could you please,
sir,
I fucking hate that.
And I that you know what I do then I through gritted teeth,
just say ma'am,
back a hundred times.
I'm sorry ma'am.
Yes ma'am.
Thank you ma'am.
Ma'Am,
could you stop Mami?
Me,
ma'am.
You fucking cunt,
I'm sorry.
That's a little bit of fucking half an ounce of rage ahead to get out there.
Let me get back to hype in my dates here.
So anyways,
this week,
oh,
what a week I have,
I'm going to be at the record theater for two shows.
I believe the second show was already sold out.
So,
uh,
if you want to get tickets,
you better fucking hustle there all for you fucking contents,
the Goddamn Internet.
We're not working in this room.
You know,
I really need to step my life up.
I'm,
I'm at the record theater at this,
uh,
this Friday,
April 8th for two shows.
I believe they're like eight and 10 are eight and 10 30.
I don't know what the fuck they are.
My God damn website won't come up.
Um,
that's in Baltimore outside of Baltimore,
Maryland.
And on Friday night I'm at the Tower Tower Theater in Philadelphia,
Pennsylvania.
Later on this month,
I got two more shows.
One is in Milwaukee,
Wisconsin.
April 22nd at the PAPP's theater.
Um,
unbelievable response by the way.
I want to thank everybody beforehand in Milwaukee.
Maybe that's why I had the Laverne and Shirley Song in my head.
Isn't that where that show was based at?
Um,
and they also worked at a beer factory.
It's all coming full circle and on the 23rd,
I'll be at the uh,
Royal Oak Theater in Detroit,
Michigan.
Um,
both of those dates are selling unbelievably well.
Both of them are going to sell out,
so get your tickets as soon as you can.
And uh,
I want to thank everybody there for like,
I have not,
I've never played Milwaukee and I have not played Detroit since I did.
Uh,
the rich bitch tour,
the Chappelle show tour back in.
I think I did that in an oh four.
I,
all I've done is I've done like kickers and that type of stuff outside of
Detroit,
but I haven't been in Detroit.
I guess it's Royal Oak.
I have no idea.
And then the last one is actually sold out.
It's one of those antisocial comedy,
um,
comedy tour dates and that one is a Jim Norton put the tour together.
Jim Norton from a little Jimmy from the opiod.
Anthony show best radio show out there for my money.
Uh,
Jim Norton,
Jim Breuer,
David telling myself are all doing a comedy tour.
We just added some dates.
We have a date in Washington DC on May 13th.
We have one in June,
I believe it's at the Chicago theater.
These are all@antisocialcomedy.com.
Uh,
I believe that one is June 15th,
I think.
I don't know.
All of that is on antisocial comedy.com.
Just click on tour dates.
Those dates are all on sale.
Um,
you know,
please come down.
You get,
you get for comics for the price of one.
We're playing some of the most beautiful venues in the country.
More dates are going to follow because the turnout has been unbelievable.
Ticket sales have been fantastic.
So that's the podcast for this week.
Uh Oh real quick.
Jay Miller,
one of my favorite enforcers of the Boston Bruins is in,
uh,
is in the hospital recovering from pneumonia.
Just want to send him a get well soon wishes.
Um,
one of my favorites and a,
we're going to send a link,
a youtube video.
We've got some great youtube videos this week.
I almost forgot about those.
We're going to have one of Jay Miller holding his own against the greatest of
all time for my money.
Bob Probert and a,
what are the youtube videos for this week?
Oh,
we got some good ones.
I got one from that show.
Cheaters,
you know,
let's show cheaters with a gun.
You know,
they basically,
uh,
somebody thinks that somebody is cheating on them.
So then what do they do?
They get,
they hired this company and they start spying on the boyfriend and girlfriend.
And when they confirm that they are in fact cheating,
they show up and confront him.
And this is one of the greatest ones I've ever seen.
They confront this kid at a,
at an ice rink after he just played a hockey game and you know,
usually the person who's cheating,
you know the dude is absolutely stunned.
This guy handles it absolutely perfectly.
He fucking breaks up with her.
She shows up.
She's like,
you know,
cause the chickies cheating with,
is that the ice rink?
She says,
yeah,
who the fuck is that?
You know,
what the fuck are you doing here?
And he just goes,
he just breaks up with her right on the spot.
He's leaning on his stick white wipe on the snow.
I mean the,
the,
the sweat off of his fucking nose.
He looks like a hockey player in between periods going like,
yeah,
we got to work on our for checking and I hope we can get that goal back in the
second period he wasn't even sweating and he just breaks up with her.
She's like,
yeah,
who the fuck is that?
What the fuck are you doing?
He just goes,
he goes,
yeah,
we're done.
What do you mean with done?
Just like that.
He goes,
yeah,
it's over.
She goes,
that girl,
because the other girl was uglier.
She goes,
you're going to dump me for that girl.
And he goes,
what can I say?
She,
she does it right.
And he,
he didn't,
he didn't give a fuck.
He was barely looking at her.
He was just sitting there leaning on his stick.
He wasn't nervous that there was cameras there and he just fucking breaks up
with there and then his girlfriend doesn't know what to do.
She's so she ends up getting into a fist fight with the chickies cheating on and
he just sort of walks away into the locker room.
It's fucking phenomenal.
Um,
what else do we got?
We have some hippie chick trying to give a presentation to a bunch of corporate
people.
Um,
what the hell are these youtube videos?
We got Paul Orndorff hyping the Hulk Hulkamania workout thing.
That's one of my favorites.
And A,
we got a couple of others.
They're all going to be up at the [inaudible] podcast.com.
And like I stated earlier,
if you want to send emails to this podcast,
uh,
the new email address is bill
mm,
podcast.com please keep them calm and you guys emails.
They get better each week.
Uh,
that's it.
You guys all have a great weekend.
Great weekend.
A great week.
All right.
I go fuck yourself.
I'll talk to you next week.
[inaudible]
Huh?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
Huh?
okay.